happy birthday to you so guess what city
I'm in Washington DC our nation's
capital it is the seat of power for the
United States of America our country may
be young but what a history we have so
join me as the Beast checks out for
beauty there's a zillion freaking people
here that that hasn't changed it's a
little disconcerting lots of vehicles
what I notice about DC is is very clean
and it's set up very well for tourism
and people to have access to the
monuments and the history of the locale
this was a very picturesque shot
Time magazine Life magazine of the
waiting pool the Washington Monument and
the posters protesting the war this is
important Martin Luther King this is all
very important stuff here you know it's
part of my personal history when I come
to visit you show me what you like not
what I like I want to experience learn
and do everything there is to do so here
I am Washington DC hungry want to get
some grub Ben's Chili Bowl absolutely
iconic Ben here at this location one of
the longest-running continuous
businesses of this modern era good food
historic I'm all for that what is the
most iconic thing what we're known for
our specialty is what we called an
and we also recommend chili cheese fries
yummy I can't wait to try the food buon
apetito Ben's Chili Bowl very good you
can tell that some homemade chili and
it's got just the right amount of kick
to make it interesting but not so much
that I'll have to do the rest of eating
makes me jumpy I'm liking a little kid
in my head I'm singing a little good
song alright look at that there's my
eyes hey life below zero above zero you
never know who you're gonna meet you
never know what you're gonna learn
I'm Susan I'm from Alaska this is the
Supreme Court building I was so excited
I got to meet a little Secret Service
Buchi this picture for me so yay
Urmi mommy's taking pictures my sixteen
and a half year old retired sled dog
can't come with me on the little city
tours but I'm bringing her some little
eye candy for when she gets home
all righty oh look he's backing up you
get a parking spot oh wow there's a lot
of horses what the heck is up with that
that's a beautiful horse you're welcome
hello president mrs. Obama and guess
what an honor - to see the white house
named quite aptly I'm actually quite
surprised that I can get as close as
this the you know for general public I
know that the President and mrs. Obama
are kind of really bummed that they're
not getting to meet with me I was just
too busy today not a shabby place it may
not be Buckingham Palace but it's
you see the tourists you see the smiles
on the faces and it does make a damn
proud to be an American I'm gonna have
to come again tighten up the girdles
kavik so we'll be back